this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer when Hurricane
sandy struck New York on October 29th
2012 it pushed a deluge of water through
the city breaking the city's coastal
defenses with ease flooding homes
subways and businesses alike it's
inundated electric facilities causing
power outages across the city
all told the storm and flooding is
estimated to have caused nineteen
billion dollars of damage and tragically
claimed the lives of 43 people how
cities react to adversity like this
tells you a great deal about their
character and New York responded swiftly
the flooding that hurricane sandy caused
was an unfortunate combination of
factors as the hurricane traced its path
along the eastern coast of the United
States they looked set to curve out into
the Atlantic a glancing blow for New
York but it's merch was halted when a
high pressure zone from the north
blocked its progress causing the
counterclockwise spiraling storm to
whip-its winds into New York the storm
pushed a wall of water across the
Atlantic arriving at its peak at 9:24
p.m. just a half hour after a full moon
high tide it's impossible to predict
when the next storm like this will hit
New York but we do know the likelihood
of flooding is rising looking at high
water events in lower Manhattan over the
past 70 years we can Paris some data
besides the clear increase in frequency
of extreme high water events in the past
decade thanks to increases in
frequencies and hurricanes these data
points don't show any real trend
Hurricane sandy broke records but
singular data points like this aren't
particularly useful let's attribute each
individual foot of sea level height to
the three primary factors that drivers
tide level storm surge and sea level
rise as a result of climate change since
the start of the 18th century now let's
set a pair we absolutely do not want to
cross
a 10.5 feet of high water the New York
City subway system floods in September
1960 the subway came within just a half
foot of flooding if we adjust the sea
level rise attributed to climate change
to the present day September 1962 would
have passed this critical level this is
not a prediction this is a measurable
sea level rise humans have been
measuring sea levels for a long time
it's a simple task of placing a ruler by
the water sea level rise is going to
continue this is an irrefutable fact the
ocean is warming water expands when it
heats the estimated thermal expansion of
the Opera is 700 meters of the sea
between 1971 and 2010 as a result of a
warming rate of 0.01 5 degrees Celsius
per decade will result in sea level
rises between 0.4 and 0.8 millimeters
per year you can dismiss this data you
can argue against it you can ignore
simple scientific principles you are
free to buy a home in a projected flood
zone the world will go on however the
rest of us will continue the logical
steps of preparation Hurricane sandy
caused nineteen billion dollars of
damage if that 19 billion dollars of
wealth had instead been used to prepare
New York's coastline what could it have
achieved we know storm surge barriers
work the Netherlands has proven that
these systems work they have built an
entire network of storm surge barriers
that not only protect their existing
cities but help reclaimed once unusable
land from the sea we have covered their
use of storm surge barriers in the past
so we won't go into the engineering
detail but a link for that video will be
attached in the end card of this video
for you to watch after this one
potential storm surge barrier locations
have been planned for New York with two
primary options three smaller storm
surge barriers could be placed one in
the Narrows one at Arthur Kill and
another on the East River alternatively
a large storm surge barrier could
Connect New Jersey to the Rockaway
Peninsula with another barrier in the
East River
once again these would without a doubt
provide immense protection for New York
but for now the plans were rejected for
a number of reasons one the costs were
too high
potentially costing up to 25 billion to
the design approval and construction
process could take up to three decades
to complete three massive levees would
have to be constructed along the nearby
coastline such as the Rockaway Peninsula
to ensure a storm surge couldn't simply
go around the barriers this would
significantly alter the terrain of these
highly populated areas which likely
wouldn't go down well with the residents
for the barriers could cause more severe
flooding for areas not protected by them
like Long Island and those to the
northeast of the East River barrier and
finally the barriers would have a
significant environmental impact on the
ecology of the bay I cannot imagine that
New York a city with a GDP over 1.5
trillion dollars would continue shunning
the idea of a storm surge barrier if the
risks continue to rise however for now
they have gone for a more community
driven approach and this is what they
came up with this is the map of the plan
proposed in 2013 just a year after the
devastation of Hurricane sandy it's a
drastic overhaul of its coastal defences
priced at a cost of 20 billion just over
if you count 1 billion as just over the
estimated cost of damage from Hurricane
sandy it's a complex variety of
localized multi-purpose protections this
was the general path the storm surge
took through New York City when
Hurricane sandy struck the first part of
this plan is to create barriers in the
water to remove some of the kinetic
energy and reduced the height and power
in the waves the first line of Defense's
here will be offshore breakwaters
located in these locations a living
breakwater project due for construction
this year of the South Shore of Staten
Island will consist of a rock mound
covered with a bedding stone layer these
rocks will be
chosen and textured to encourage a
revival in local ecologies like oyster
reefs other on land projects will also
aim to reduce wave power and provide
protection like living shorelines and
wetland areas highlighted in these
regions on the map
Brooklyn Bridge Park is a living
shoreline that was built before
Hurricane sandy struck and had held up
incredibly well and fulfilled its
purpose of protecting the residents of
Brooklyn flooding but keeping the water
out of the Brooklyn streets the plants
here like the pitch pines along the
stabilized shoreline are salt resistant
the soil of the park has a high sand
content to help saltwater drain away
quickly and if needed the irrigation
system of the park has been designed to
flush saltwater out of the soil if there
are many more projects like this planned
for around New York and they differ
depending on the terrain and space
available soon after Hurricane sandy New
York City began constructing 7.2
kilometres of 4 meter high sand dunes
here on the Rockaway Peninsula built
simply with sandbags covered with sand
and stabilized with grasses and fencing
a cheap solution that fits the natural
environment and will help prevent the
damaging flooding that occurred here in
2012 and this approach of beach
reinforcements and beach nourishment
will be used in these locations smart
localized soft strategies like this
helped a lot but they earned enough
sometimes a harder engineered solution
is needed bulkheads retaining walls and
levees are planned in these locations
these don't need much explaining they
are elevated hard barriers to storm
surges in other areas where it would be
cheaper and less damaging to block the
surge at the entrance to an English
smaller storm surge barriers have been
proposed like the Rockaway inless
Newtown Creek and Gowanus Canal all of
which allowed the storm surge in 2012 to
penetrate deep into New York City
neighborhoods by far the most
interesting solution is the big you a 16
kilometre loop around Manhattan the
jewel in NYC scram
the big you will use a variety of
solutions to living shorelines with
natural park levees that will double as
parks for the residents will be used in
places like Battery Park on the tip of
lower Manhattan deployable walls like
these on a river in Austria will be
attached to the underside of the
elevated highway along the two bridges
and Chinatown areas which will flip down
when needed a bridging berm will run for
3.5 kilometers from East 13th Street to
core Lear's Hook Park this design has
already been awarded 335 million dollars
from the federal government for
implementation and will consist of
Natural Park bridges to connect the East
River Park to the neighboring areas with
ambitious plans to cover FDR highway
completely with more park amenities this
will effectively raise the riverbank by
nine feet four feet above hurricane
Sandy's high-water mark this pattern of
community driven solutions will continue
and wrap right around Manhattan
protecting it from storm surges and
raising the critical sea level / a
little further out of reach while some
of these projects have begun
construction and even been completed
there are many more which have been
blocked by local residents this would be
easy to dismiss these people as NIMBYs
or climate change deniers and that is
true for many but hopefully this video
will do what it was intended to do to
show the positive impacts projects like
these can have on communities New York
is a city that has the financial capital
to back projects like this up but these
are issues which affect all cities
around the world my own hometown of
Galway has been pummeled with increasing
numbers of storms every year that has
seen many buildings flooded and carries
damaged this problem is only going to
get worse over time and we need to
prepare and work towards minimizing
climate change by investing in
renewables nuclear and other low-carbon
energy sources I just started a series
about Europe's transition to 100%
renewable starting with a critical first
step grid interconnectors which will
allow European countries to
raid excess renewable energy you can
watch this or learn more about how solar
energy works by completing this course
in solar energy on brilliant in this
course you will learn the principle
methods of harvesting energy from
sunlight whether that be from
concentrated solar power or photovoltaic
cells and it gradually introduces you to
more complicated engineering principles
as you master each section brilliants
mission is to help people achieve their
learning goals so whether you're a
student a professional brushing up or
learning cutting-edge topics or someone
who just wants to understand the world
better you should check out brilliant
set a goal to improve yourself and then
work at that goal a little bit every day
brilliant makes that easy with
interactive explorations and a mobile
app that you can use on the go if you
are naturally curious want to build your
problem-solving skills or need to
develop confidence in your analytical
abilities then get brilliant premium to
learn something new every day
brilliant thought-provoking math science
and computer science content helps guide
you to mastery by taking complex
concepts and breaking them up into
bite-sized understandable chunks you'll
start by having fun with their
interactive explorations over time
you'll be amazed at what you
accomplished as always thanks for
watching
and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below
you